ganze städte könnten im wasser schweben
manche architekten erträumen sich
komplett schwimmen besiedlungen
parkanlagen auf dem wasser oder
schwimmende gebetshäuser die die
kulturen zusammenbringen könnten
visionen wie diese will das
niederländische architektenbüro waters
studio zur realität machen
seit zwölf jahren bringt gründer kultus
mit seinem team der architektur das
schwimmen bei
die ansprüche sind dabei immer größer
geworden denken oft nur über die gebäude
nach aber ich glaube wir müssen die
städte an sich neu denken
ich möchte zeigen dass wasser ein teil
davon sein kann es ist nicht nur eine
bedrohung sondern ein teil der lösung
zum beispiel für fantastisch anmutende
projekte wie dieses im norwegischen
tromsö soll in zukunft ein
fünf-sterne-hotel in form eines
schneekristall unter dem nordlicht
schwimmen das kristall hotel ist bereits
voll finanziert wartet aber noch auf
genehmigungen
während diese schwimmende insel noch
2016 gebaut und auf die malediven
transportiert werden soll
wegen seiner visionären entwürfe wird
kuhn alltours mittlerweile von experten
zu den wichtigsten innovatoren des
einundzwanzigsten jahrhunderts gezählt
ich habe mich in den letzten 15 jahren
komplett diesem thema gewidmet
und wir erleben jetzt gerade einen
durchbruch die zukunft wird nass es gibt
klimawandel und wachsende städte
gemeinden und architekten begreifen
jetzt dass wir uns in richtung
schwimmende stadtentwicklung
rund ein viertel der fläche der
niederlande liegt unterhalb des
meeresspiegels gefahren die das mit sich
bringt beschäftigen die architekten hier
schon lange schwimmende bauten sind
nicht neu aber in den letzten zehn
jahren ist ihre zahl steil angestiegen
rund 300.000 schwimmende wohnhäuser gibt
es in den niederlanden bereits problem
ist gar nicht so sehr die technologie es
sind die baugesetze sie müssen die
regierungen überzeugen sie anzupassen
die fragen ist das jetzt ein brot oder
ein haus sie müssen erst begreifen dass
häuser auf wasser genauso möglich sind
wie auf dem land leben und arbeiten auf
dem wasser der unternehmer olaf janßen
hat sich diesen traum erfüllt
kostenfaktor für das dreistöckige haus
und den liegeplatz 650.000 euro nicht
gerade ein budget für jedermann
trotzdem sieht olaf janßen für die
schwimmenden häuser potenzial
wer am viele besuchern alle sind
begeistert von den großzügigen raum und
der aussicht natürlich fragen auch alle
ist es nicht wirklich wenn es stimmt
wenn sie dann mal hier waren bei sturm
und merken dass das haus sich kaum
bewegt überlegen sie sich vielleicht
auch ihr nächstes haus ein schwimmendes
sein könnte auch in anderen ländern
wechseln architekten ins fließende
element an einer portugiesischen
universität entstand dieses konzept das
haus floating kann feriendomizil oder
richtiges zuhause seien diese modelle
von water studio gehen in kürze in bau
wasser wählen und ganze schwimmende
inseln alles projekte für superreiche
zukunftsweisende architektur soll aber
mehr können
deshalb entwickelte studio in
zusammenarbeit mit der unesco auch
projekte für die ärmsten finde ich es
kann nicht nur um die reichen gehen
wir mussten mit dieser art von projekten
zwar anfangen die gleiche technologie
können wir aber jetzt nutzen um die
wirklichen probleme zu lösen
eine milliarde menschen leben total
verarmt in slums auf direkt am wasser
wenn wir dafür über das wasser lösungen
bringen können schulen energieversorgung
andere technologien dann können wir
wirklich etwas verändern
ein leben auf dem wasser wird von der
idee mehr und mehr zur realität